Many teams run their AI strategy the
same way they order takeout. Pick
something that looks good online and pay
the premium only to discover later that
it's half warm and nothing like the
photos. Why? The expectations are too
high. Scroll LinkedIn or Twitter and you
will see the recommended prefix menu
with malt and graphs and bleeding edge
models.
That might make sense when you're
cooking for millions of customers, but
inside your company, that's like paying
for truffles to garnish your instant
noodles. We followed a different recipe
and it delivered millions of dollars of
revenue. Today, I want to share it with
you. So first the proof and then the
recipe that got us
there. In Q1 2024 we faced the classic
dilemma build or buy. We chose to build
two devs and roughly 10 plus sprint
weeks of effort clear. We had a system
that resulted in several million dollars
of ARR and a group level award. I can't
share the exact numbers. Legal would
sate me, but imagine a number big enough
that finance stops asking why
build. Let me show you why Twitter's
recipe would have killed us. Giant
evals, multi-agent systems, RF models.
It looks delicious, costs a fortune, and
delays a launch.
It's perfect for fleshy SAS demos, but
an overkill for your in-house needs. But
the question really isn't what to skip.
It's when does it ever make
sense. Think of it this way. S is a
hotel buffet. It's generic but safe.
Your internal users want the grandma's
secret sauce, not the hotel eggs.
So let's see where that home kitchen
crushes the buffet
option shines when you need vendor
integrations or crossindustry best
practices. Our kitchen wins when we
already own the battery, I mean the
data. Our colleagues know the exact key
strokes needed to close the deals and we
can involve them in double-checking the
outputs. And the advantages don't stop
there because we sit next door to our
users. So a tweak ships the same days
and the UI speaks their language and the
computer runs on infra we mostly pay for
already. It all basically drops the cost
to pennies.
So the rule of thumb is buy says explore
the unknown but build inhouse once the
workflow is
yours. Okay. So pantry is stocked knives
are out. Here are the five
lessons. They work best as a set. So we
will unpack them in order starting from
the foundation.
This is where in-house crushes says you
can go absurdly deep on one painful job
to be done without chasing total
addressable market. Pick something where
you can easily pinpoint the value event
which is that dollarbased outcome that
you're doing it all for. Remember that
one. It's going to be important later.
We started with a simple sales alert use
case and grew it from
there by going deep on that one use
case. It was all made much easier. We
didn't stop at the
alerts. What were they for? What else
needed to be done? All those were
questions we had. And who knows best
what's
needed? your
users. Talk to them to really nail it.
If you stay focused, you can keep things
very simple and avoid anything
agentic. So, metrics coming next.
Spoiler offline evals never sign a
contract. Nobody at the board meeting
asks for your F1 score or NDCG.
They ask did it move the
revenues. Don't get me wrong, evils are
important, but they are smoke alarms.
You need to track the actual
money. So, instrument everything until
you can say this AI task led to $20
here. Build your revenue funnel.
everything from beginning to end to that
value event that we talked about
earlier. By the way, your users are your
guard rails. So you can run ambitious
experiments. Don't overthink your
evils. And once you link your system to
dollars, decisions and prioritization
become a breeze. The conversation shifts
to what's your idea and how much would
you sell with
it? And here is where it gets
interesting. Managers will start asking
for team performance reports.
You should automate them, but also
prepare the leaderboards because those
can really create that healthy
competition, get leadership invested,
surface some
champions, but also help those who might
be silently struggling with the new
workflows. So, now that you're tracking
the dollars, don't wait for users to
come to you. You need to become the chef
who anticipates what the next dish
should be because the best UI is the one
you never need to use. This is your
business. So you know what the next
steps should be. So why wait for users
to ask for it? Just do it for
them. In our case, we build a motion to
send daily digests. Here is what you
need to know today.
We still had shed UI, but it was the
fallback for all the unexpected and
unplanned tasks that came along. So,
what's next? Now that we've stopped
waiting the tables, now it's time to
turn those freed up minutes into money
on the
register. Your AI system needs to guide
action, not just deliver information.
Why?
Because saving 30 minutes is worthless
if users just fill it with an email
sludge. So the real power here comes
from you actually converting the time
saved into time well spent because you
know what the highest value activities
are. And more you start building up
those revenue funnels, the more you will
start to understand where to divert that
free time and your users attention.
Our proactive system was a hit. It was
surfacing things users wouldn't have
thought of doing. And compared to the
chat app, it had 20 points higher MPS
and order of magnitude higher
engagement. So, you're making some money
now, but it brings us to a critical
decision point. Where to invest your
limited development resources? You might
not like the answer.
Good data consistently beats great
models. This is the secret that you
won't find on
Twitter. We all love shiny things, but
03 is 60 times more expensive and order
of magnitude slower compared to 41 mini.
So the biggest impact if you put it in
production will be on the cost. We've
seen the best results from simply adding
more triggers to alert the user zone and
going deeper into what they
needed. Boring, right? But it worked.
When we changed the models from normal
to the miniseries and back, the only
thing that changed were the costs and
the
evils. So you need to build for what
your users need, not what you want to
try.
When you focus on what users true value
instead of simply chasing model
benchmarks, something magical happens. A
powerful flywheel begins to
spin
because those tight feedback loops make
users feel hurt. So they start providing
you with ideas for improvements.
So you can run vehicle experiments based
on their feedback which drives even more
adoption which generates more data for
prioritization and more
ideas. The revenue fly wheel starts
spinning faster and
faster. So that's it. Let's recap what
we've covered so you can apply it
immediately.
Focus on one painful job to be done that
has clear dollar value. Don't try to
bowl the ocean with a comprehensive
solution. Revenue impact trumps
evaluation metrics. Track everything to
the final dollar-based outcome and make
decisions based on that. push insights
proactively rather than waiting for
users
questions. And simply being proactive
isn't enough. You need to ensure that
those time savings are channeled into
the highest value activities you can
find and invest in the basics. Um it
really pays off. So in short, start
small, follow the money, and let your
users guide
you. Thank you.